practiquemos la identificación de grupos
funcionales en diferentes compuestos
esta molécula de la izquierda la podemos
encontrar en los perfumes busquemos a
alguno de los grupos funcionales que
vimos en los vídeos anteriores aquí
tenemos un doble enlace carbono carbono
entonces este es un al que no este es el
grupo funcional al que no y por acá
tenemos otro doble enlace carbono
carbono un al que no ahora cuál será
este grupo funcional tenemos un bache y
el resto de la molécula
h es un alcohol así que también tenemos
un alcohol en este compuesto ahora
veamos la aspirina que grupos
funcionales podemos encontrar bueno aquí
hay un anillo aromático así que tenemos
un grupo funcional areno y que tenemos
arriba aquí tenemos un h y el oxígeno
está unido directamente a un carbón y lo
entonces tenemos un h y el oxígeno está
unido directamente a un carbono unido
con un doble enlace a un oxígeno y luego
tenemos el resto de la molécula este es
un ácido carboxílicos espero que lo
hayan reconocido ácido
carboxílicos para el siguiente grupo
funcional tenemos un oxígeno que está
unido directamente a un carbón y lo
entonces tenemos un oxígeno unido a un
carbón y lo de un lado y al resto de la
molécula del otro que sería esta parte y
del otro lado del carbón y lo tenemos
otro grupo r grupo r esto es un este
r ese doble enlace o r es un esther así
que tenemos un grupo funcional esther en
la molécula de aspirina ahora echemos un
vistazo a los errores más comunes que le
ocurren a los estudiantes uno de ellos
es confundir un ácido carboxílicos con
un alcohol déjenme dibujar un ácido
carboxílicos
muchas veces los estudiantes se
encuentran con esto y dicen ah aquí hay
un bache y luego está el resto de la
molécula debe ser un alcohol pero
observen que este oxígeno está unido a
un carbón y lo por eso es un ácido
carboxílicos pero si alejamos el bache
del carbón y lo dibujemos un ejemplo
aquí tenemos nuestro carbón hilo y el h
está más lejos ahora si tenemos un
alcohol podemos decir que tenemos un
bache y luego el resto de la molécula
este es un alcohol y cuál sería este
grupo tenemos un carbón hilo con un
grupo red de un lado y un grupo r del
otro entonces esto es un acetona cuando
tenemos un carbón hilo con un grupo r de
un lado y un grupo r del otro que puede
ser el mismo grupo r o diferente se
expresa como r prima entonces esto es un
acetona así que tenemos una sector y un
alcohol tenemos dos grupos funcionales
en el mismo compuesto
pero que puedan ver la diferencia entre
este compuesto y este este es un ácido
carboxílicos y este tiene un acetona y
un alcohol muy bien otro error muy común
ocurre en este grupo funcional de la
aspirina los estudiantes ven este
oxígeno y dicen tengo un oxígeno y tengo
un grupo r de un lado y un grupo r del
otro lado entonces un grupo r un oxígeno
y un grupo r esto es un éter bueno r&r
sin duda representa al éter pero como
aquí tenemos un carbón y lo unido
directamente al oxígeno
este es un este y cómo podemos
transformarlo a un éter bueno voy a
redibujar el anillo
y luego pongamos el ácido carboxílicos
arriba
de este lado después de dibujar al
oxígeno quitamos el carbón y no ahora si
tenemos un éter porque tenemos un
oxígeno con un grupo r de un lado y el
resto de la molécula del otro lado
este es un éter espero que puedan ver la
diferencia siempre tomen en cuenta el
carbón y lo cuando se encuentre unido
directamente al oxígeno y eso será un
este muy bien otros errores que los
estudiantes suelen cometer es una mezcla
de los dos grupos funcionales que hay en
estas moléculas empecemos con benzal de
ido que por su nombre podemos adivinar
que tenemos un aldehído primero tenemos
nuestro anillo aromático o arena y
después tenemos una leído
es decir un carbón hilo y luego un
hidrógeno unido directamente al carbono
en el carbón y lo entonces tenemos un
grupo r después un carbón hilo y luego
un hidrógeno este es un aldehído pero si
quitamos el hidrógeno y ponemos un ch 3
nos quedará el compuesto de la derecha
aquí tenemos un ch 3 unido directamente
a este carbono en el carbón y lo así que
tenemos un grupo r en ambos lados del
carbón y lo es decir r
y doble enlace o r esto es una acetona
que incluso podríamos adivinar por el
nombre del compuesto así que tenemos un
acetona entonces la diferencia es muy
clara pero es importante mencionarlo
porque muchos se confunden con esto los
aldehídos tienen un hidrógeno unido
directamente a este carbono en el carbón
hilo pero si no hay un hidrógeno
entonces hablamos de un acetona rc doble
enlace o r es un acetona finalmente
veamos un compuesto muy grande con
muchos grupos funcionales diferentes a
esta molécula se le llama atenolol y es
un betabloqueante eso significa que es
un fármaco muy fuerte identifiquemos a
los grupos funcionales
y tenemos un anillo aromático o arena
tenemos un harén o después tenemos un
oxígeno con un grupo r de un lado y un
grupo r del otro r&r sabemos que es un
éter también tenemos un éter después
tenemos un h y luego el resto de la
molécula r&h corresponde a un alcohol
también tenemos un alcohol y después
tenemos un hidrógeno con un par de
electrones libres un grupo r de un lado
y un grupo r del otro entonces es una
mina
tenemos una mina
y finalmente del lado izquierdo aquí es
en donde hay confusión
tenemos un hidrógeno con un par de
electrones libres podríamos decir que es
una mina pero observen que este
nitrógeno está unido a un carbón y lo
entonces es una amiga esto corresponde a
una amiga
la diferencia entre una mina y una amiga
dibujaré otro compuesto aquí tenemos un
nh 2 y un carbón y lo en este caso
tenemos un hidrógeno unido directamente
al carbono en el carbón y lo entonces es
una amiga y podemos mover estos
electrones hacia acá empujando a estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno así que la
resonancia es posible en una amiga
a medida pero si movemos al nitrógeno
lejos del carbón y lo lo dibujaré por
aquí
tenemos el carbón y lo y ahora el
nitrógeno está más lejos observen que no
podemos dibujar una estructura de
resonancia entonces tenemos una mina
esto es una mina
y que grupo funcional tenemos aquí bueno
tenemos un carbón hilo con un grupo r de
un lado y un grupo r del otro así que
tenemos un acetona tenemos una zona y
una lámina y por acá tenemos una amiga
entonces es importante que puedan
diferenciar esto porque muchos
estudiantes se confunden con estos
grupos funcionales